we have a voicemail number that you can
call any time of day
the number is 2192 david p here is a
really interesting voicemail
about this continued topic of the
anti-cancel culture republicans
canceling one of their own
not a very big tent is what it's seeming
like take a listen to this
hey dave you know the the right that has
a very large
tent that doesn't cancel anybody like
extreme people like
lauren bover yeah and matt gates they
won't be cancelled because they don't
believe in castle culture
they want to encompass all sorts of
different voices however
after canceling liz cheney from the
canceled culture
right you have a question dave do you
think liz cheney can come back twice as
strong
and cancel the crap out of the
republican party
what is she going to do i don't think
she's going to go quietly
seriously is she going to become a
democrat no she's very conservative
right but what can she do
to get them back i have a hunch we have
not seen the last of liz cheney
i'm actually rooting for her now trollo
and brother yeah i i agree that liz
cheney won't go quietly
but i'm skeptical that there's much she
can do and the reason i say that is
the party of the republican party is
still completely
under the control of trump and trumpism
in fact the cancellation of liz cheney
is further
evidence of that we've been wondering
will they go pro-trump or anti-trump
going into 2022
will they go more in the direction of
cheney and romney or are they going to
go more in the direction of
beau bert marjorie taylor green madison
cawthorne louis gomer jim jordan
elise stefanik etc and the cancellation
of liz cheney to me is evidence that
they're going with the trump side
70 percent of the voters still believe
trump actually won
two-thirds of the republican voters that
70 percent of republican voters
two-thirds of republican voters claim
they'd follow trump to another party
they are choosing to get rid of liz
cheney for something
from leadership she's still in the house
for something
as seemingly uncontroversial as what
should be uncontroversial of just saying
oh the election results are the results
and trump lost
shouldn't be even uh shouldn't even be
anything
um and yet she is losing her leadership
role because of that so
while i agree that liz cheney does not
seem like the type
to just go quietly uh i am un
unsure about what she actually will be
able to do substantively because this
party seems to have gone
fully in with trump for 2022 as of what
we're seeing for the for the
in the immediate if you see it
differently let me know but that's the
way it's looking uh to me
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today a homeless man has been awarded a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars
as a judge has tossed out st louis
county
anti-panhandling ordinances this is very
interesting and the precedent that it
sets could be meaningful and long
lasting in terms of how we
criminalize homelessness in many parts
of the country
number two a judge has dismissed the nra
bankruptcy case
making it more likely the nra may be
dissolved
uh cautious optimism there and we will
also talk about
new york city mayoral candidate andrew
yang
now in hot water with a bunch of
different people
over a tweet he sent about the
israeli-palestinian conflict followed by
a letter he put out this morning we'll
explain all of it
and discuss the implications all of
those stories and
more on today's bonus show how do you
get the bonus show
a lot of people are wondering and the
answer remains
very simple sign up at joinpakman.com
that's it
it's cheap it's quick it's easy you
support the show
and if you would like a discount off of
that membership to hear our takes on all
of these extra stories
use the coupon code better21 you save
big
you get 100 of the benefits at a major
discount join pacman.com
we'll see everybody on the bonus show